our brussels correspondent christine
mundo is covering this story and joins
us now christine remind us again of how
the northern ireland customs issue is
currently dealt with under the brexit
agreement i know this is complicated but
try to put it in a nutshell if you can
that's right terry the eu has specific
food rules especially when it comes to
products like meat
uh and eggs and and the block requires
that goods coming in specifically from
non-eu countries are subjected to
customs checks now because of the
political history which is very
sensitive between ireland and northern
ireland brexit negotiators thought it
wise not to impose a hard border
between ireland and northern ireland
which is effectively the kind of
instrument that you would need to be
able to facilitate these very strict
checks that the eu requires on its
product so the work around there
was that all goods coming from the rest
of great britain that is england
scotland and wales would be checked in
northern ireland a special arrangement
was made for northern ireland which kept
northern ireland in the single eu market
in the in the sense that northern
ireland still keeps to eu standards so
any goods coming in to northern ireland
from the rest of of britain are subject
to those eu standards what the british
government is now seeking to do is for
example propose
two lanes at that border one processing
goods that are coming in uh from from
the rest of of britain that are destined
to stay in northern ireland which the uk
government says should only be subject
to uk standards and then another lane
for goods that are destined for the rest
of the european union that would be
coming from britain but
this in simple uh words terry is of
course going against what was agreed
upon uh in that northern ireland
protocol that came into effect at the
end of 2021
if boris johnson does unilaterally
change the terms of that deal on
northern ireland what impact could that
have on trade with the eu
terry there are people are starting to
use the words trade war could we see a
trade war between between brussels uh
and london and by all indication that
that is that is likely what happens in a
trade war that is of course two trade
partners start to increase the tariffs
and the quotas on goods that makes
imports and exports more expensive that
means some companies go out of business
there is also an inflationary aspect to
that because goods become more expensive
and at a time in europe both in the
united kingdom and in europe where
people are seeing the cost of their
living soil because of the energy crisis
among other things that would be really
really detrimental businesses companies
going out of business would also mean
that there are potential job losses
on both sides in the long run trade wars
have been known to show that they have a
sort of depressive economic uh impacts
but there's also the political impact to
all of this right now europe is facing
its biggest security threat since the
end of uh world war ii uh with russia's
invasion of ukraine right now western
unity and solidarity is needed more than
ever uh and this of course the straining
and souring relations between london and
brussels over over
over this issue would of course be
detrimental to that unity and resolve
that the west is seeking at this very
difficult time
okay there could be legal implications
here too of course the eu is threatening
legal action if the uk breaks the
current agreement what sort of legal
action are we talking about here
christine
well you can expect to see the the the
uk um
excuse me the european union uh argue
that uh the uk is effectively breaching
international law that is because the
northern ireland protocol um was put
into international law and by all
accounts the british government is
making the concession that it is
contravened that it is uh in a way
undermining its obligations to
international law it argues that the
doctrine of
necessity uh warrants that that is for a
court of law to determine but but the
eu's um uh vice commission president
marius chelsea said this he said the
unilateral action is damaging to to
mutual trust he said that this will
simply bring further legal uncertainty
for the people and businesses in
northern ireland the eu says it is
interested in negotiating some of the
concerns on the uk government side uh
but given the momentum of this bill and
and sources in the uk saying that
it's looking as though the government is
likely to get it or get a vote in before
the summer recess it takes away the
concept of these two parties perhaps
negotiating this and ultimately leading
into some kind of legal action on the
grounds that the uk is breaking
international law
christine thank you very much that was
our correspondent christine munoz in
brussels